so my friend she loved unicorns for her
best area of order of crane ea2 so for
my brother's 21st birthday our random a
Brandon Ferrari and he breaks it all
around Hollywood yeah you got money
i won so for my birthday you're not 16
for my 16th birthday I had a crazy fight
with all my cousin from Barack no for my
21st birthday I asked my dad to get me a
pug but he got me a pig and said can be
but I said Pig but I said I shouldn't
tell it tell us : why don't you know it
was my birthday
my whole family came and then my cousin
came he's a little bit off I never even
met him before you [ __ ] killed
everybody me now me celebrating my
birthday
have you been to me cuz your pink hello
what would you like yeah I'll happen
very kind of the lasagne going in why
not so nice here I know I love Italy
here we are
oh thanks very for my garden and your
lasagne enjoy before you eat come on I'm
here with Avila of course I ordered the
mixed berries grouper healthy and I'll
blow she's going in with the pasta girl
she doesn't even care
Golnesa see look at a fight
now after this we should go to Milan
because I heard that the food there is
even better than it is here and will be
great with my diet because everything is
organic Golden State's everything is
processed and you only have so much and
this diet and so I got zero energy from
everything I'm solar cooking lunch was
so good oblah freaking killed hers and
i'm still working on the very hashtag of
life man being sure she's hot
I don't know I'm sipping on me I studied
Florence in middle school really hmm
look that does Michelangelo's old study
where him and his girlfriend needs to be
both about something research who for
that that's Raphael is old awesome boots
and that after Leonardo used to play
pattycake to know what it means what
about that one oh that's weird on
intelligent [ __ ]
wait can you just name the corn in skin
kidding me
gosh you're such a stereotypical
American right now screams all right
then is that the queen of the Christian
Kent
whoa what's that hey guys me Amanda
Cerny thank you so much for watching my
sir nice gifts and linking and
commenting I literally read every single
one of them so thank you guys journey is
growing and I love it
I want to involve you guys even more so
what I'm doing now is I'm taking
journeys get suggestion ideas that means
you just comment below any good ideas
that you have for me and if I decide to
choose your idea I will shout you out in
my next journey skate youtube video so
keep the comments coming and is enough
it could be you love you guys and I'll
see you next week la bases